this
is maggie keenan she's the first patient
to get the kovid 19
shot in the uk the first western nation
to launch a mass vaccination program
amid the pandemic britain becomes a
testing ground
in the west you know in some parts of
the world vaccines have been rolled out
already notably the russian vaccine and
the chinese vaccine
these vaccines have not undergone
basically the rigorous process of of
testing an approval that this vaccine
has gone through and is going through
to tackle the massive logistical
challenge of vaccinating millions of
people as quickly as possible
the country's national health service or
nhs
is bringing doctors out of retirement
and deploying tens of thousands of
volunteers
this this is just so exciting it's a
momentous occasion the nhs has been
planning extensively
to deliver the largest vaccination
program in our history
so how did the uk get here so quickly
and
how is it trying to vaccinate much of
its population at record speed
today we can announce that the
government has accepted the
recommendation
from the independent medicines and
healthcare
products regulatory agency to approve
the
pfizer biontech vaccine for distribution
across the united kingdom
technically it's not a permanent
approval
rather an authorization for emergency
use
that allows the vaccine to be
immediately delivered to vulnerable
groups
one reason the uk might have moved
faster than the u.s
is the sheer size of the regulatory
agencies
the mhra has a staff of roughly 1300
while the fda has a staff of around 17
000. it's obviously a much bigger market
they have a slightly different procedure
they are going through the data perhaps
in a different way
as biontech and pfizer scientists were
busy behind the scenes developing their
vaccine
the nhs was making sure hospitals had
the equipment needed
including freezers to store vaccines at
a very low temperature of around
negative 94 degrees fahrenheit
and it trained staff on how to
administer the shots
like in this hospital in the city of
coventry we expect quite quickly to go
up to about 400 a day and then beyond
that 500 and above
and we're putting plans in place already
we're starting to plan
if we need to increase that where do we
go next
well the uk strategy for the rollout is
to first
give it to the most vulnerable people
who are at risk of
death by covet 19 and that means that
there will be
probably kind of mobile teams bringing
it to
the old people's homes bringing it to
care homes the nhs has designated 50
hubs
in hospitals across england where
vaccines are being shipped
mostly by truck from a factory in
belgium which
comes with huge logistical challenges as
the vaccine needs to be stored at such a
cold temperature
buying tech pfizer vaccine requires two
doses per person
so everyone who gets it will need a
second shot three to four weeks after
their first one
the shots will be distributed to people
based on a nine
tier priority list with an estimated six
million people who would get them first
we are aiming for those aged over 80
care home staff and then of course our
health and social care family
the us has announced a similar strategy
to prioritize the elderly and health
care workers
in the uk the government has also said
later on
it could turn sports centers and
conference halls into mass vaccination
centers
it's amazing to see the vaccine coming
out it's amazing to see this tremendous
shot in the arm for the entire nation
but we can't afford to relax now
the uk has rolled out emergency mass
vaccinations before
like in the 1960s for smallpox and 2010
for the swine flu but the covet 19
shot will be the first time this
specific type of mrna vaccine is used
since the kovit 19 vaccine is so new the
world will be watching for any potential
long-term side effects
as well as anything more they can learn
about its effectiveness
so far in the trials the the side
effects have been minor
what happens now is when in the case of
an emergency authorization normally
authorities should be keeping tabs on
every single person who receives the
vaccine
and they should be monitoring whatever
side effects come in the immediate
aftermath
of the vaccination several other
pharmaceutical companies are racing to
develop
and get approval for their own coven 19
vaccines
they'll be watching pfizer's supply
chain closely as
they expect intense demand for their
product the us
which could also authorize the pfizer
vaccine in december
will have its eye out on any potential
obstacles in the uk rollout
pfizer has already had to cut its
shipment projections for
2020 in half because of supply chain
issues this is the kind of first time
that a vaccine will be
administered in a country where where
there will be very close
and meticulous monitoring both from the
regulators from by the scientists by the
companies and obviously by the general
public in the media